[Music]
the surrender of former movie mogul
Harvey Weinstein Weinstein stands
accused of sexual assault rape and today
the hands that once held an Oscar or
handcuffed behind his back Harvey
Weinstein who is now out on bail
smiled as he left the New York Police
Station this morning the disgraced
Hollywood mogul was charged with rape
and sexual abuse in cases involving two
women he posted his million-dollar bail
in cash and was fitted with a GPS
monitoring device Harvey Weinstein is
expected to be back in court July 30th
in the meantime I'm sure there's a lot
of negotiations going on behind the
scenes could there be a plea deal that's
one possibility or will he fight this
Weinstein is denied committing any
non-consensual sex acts
one of Weinstein's most vocal accusers
actress Rose McGowan had a message for
him on megyn kelly today we got you we
got you
as for Weinstein's estranged wife a
source tells ET today that Georgina
Chapman is most worried about their two
young children quote she's trying to
shield them from the reality of this
situation as much as she possibly can
and Weinstein was in the news earlier
this week
Gweneth Paltrow opened up about the
night her then boyfriend Brad Pitt
confronted the mogul he said if you ever
make her feel uncomfortable again I'll
kill you or something like that
Gweneth told Howard Stern it happened
back in 1995 after she told Brad that
Weinstein tried to make a pass at her in
a hotel room it was like the equivalent
of throwing him against the wall it was
so fantastic he leveraged his fame and
power to protect me at a time when I
didn't have fame or power yet he's the
best
[Music]